welcome back to can you tell the
difference coming up later in the show
honey nut cheerios versus honey nut o's
can you really tell the difference but
first we begin with a smartphone
challenge here are the two contenders we
blurred the brand names so which one is
the real iPhone go on look closely and
time's up I hope you guessed the iPhone
6s on your right and the iPhone I'm
sorry the HTC One a9 on your left
what were the clues well the iPhone has
its front-facing camera on the left not
the right
the iPhone speaker holes are circular
not rectangular and the iPhones home
button is circular not pill shaped now
HTC in its fans will tell you it was
actually Apple who ripped off HTC One m7
design a few years ago Apple declined to
comment but no matter how you slice it
the a9 is cosmetically the closest thing
ever to an Android iPhone for $400 it's
a good phone but it's not as good as the
iPhone or even the best Android phones
the curved edges and the fast
fingerprint sensor not only make the a9
feel like an iPhone but make it the best
feeling Android phone out of course turn
on the screen and the Android 6.0
software very clearly tells you this is
no iPhone in fact the 1080p screen is
the main thing HTC gets better than
Apple the camera takes fabulous shots
and good lighting but in very low light
the galaxy s6 and the iPhone 6s took
noticeably better photos the selfie
camera is quite good too still there are
three reasons why I find it hard to
recommend the HTC or even the Samsung
Galaxy s6 over the new Nexus phones or
the iPhone the first performance two
units I tested lagged in certain spots
number two battery life
most days I was out of juice before the
evening it also got a half
an hour to an hour less battery than the
iPhone 6s and the two new Nexus phones
on my battery tests number 3 software I
don't care for HTC's Android changes and
the Nexus phones get software and
security updates first here's what I
would do want an Android phone with the
latest and greatest specs and software
go with Google's Nexus 6p or 5x want the
greatest feeling Android phone or phone
that looks like an iPhone but isn't an
iPhone go with the a9 just know when it
comes to the fundamentals you can tell
the difference you really can't tell the
difference